Kucera of waste to be recycled should  rise to seventy percent by 2030 from  barely half today MEP s also want to cap  landfills and flash food waste by half a  vast majority of em EPS 646 voted in  favor of fostering shareholders rights  and firms so they may have a say on how  directors are paid new countries have 30  months to apply a revised gun law that  traces weapons owned by individuals  better to prevent terrorist attack 5g  everywhere that's what Member States  should aim for by 2020 they will also  need to free up radio bandwidth for  connected objects and mobile  [Music]  ninety-eight percent of farm rabbits in  the EU are bred and battery cages the  european parliament called for healthier  and affordable alternative  [Music]